welcome to this instructor guide this
presentation will help you gain a good
understanding of our online materials as
well as see how to plan and utilize them
to teach bioinformatics to graduate
students transcriptomics one talks about
next-generation sequencing data
preparation transcriptomics 2 is a
discussion of statistical analysis and
biological interpretation
transcriptomics 3 speaks about data
science and machine learning is
introduced and finally in
transcriptomics 4 we focus on
single-cell RNA seek let's talk about
how these modules are designed and how
they can be used to help students learn
about RNA seek in the program we will
require students to complete three main
courses transcriptomics 1 2 & 3 there
are also two optional courses
introduction to bioinformatics and
transcriptomics 4 intro to
bioinformatics provides an overview of
important research topics and
applications this content is tailor
fitted to the data science novice it
offers example of big data in basic life
sciences research healthcare as well as
a biotech and pharmaceutical industries
it is designed to inspire and provide
perspective for both graduate and
undergraduate students transcriptomics 4
is a course dedicated to single-cell RNA
seek how this type of data is generated
how to analyze it in what specific
challenges need to be considered each
module in this series is designed using
five elements rationale and objectives
engaging activities multimedia and
tutorials practical applications and
quantification and testing these
elements are consistent throughout all
three courses in the transcriptomics
series each course starts with rationale
and objectives to set the expectation
for learning relevant terminology is
listed and placed in the biological
context throughout the lesson different
types of data formats are presented
linking those to the logic behind each
one of the analysis methods that are
thoroughly described each course
contains engaging activities to make the
material easier to read and remember
these include concept mapping question
analysis and an extensive glossary to
contextualize complex terminology as
well as functional linkages to help
associate bioinformatics analysis
workflows with the
functions courses are also enriched with
videos and multimedia inserts these make
the material more enjoyable and break up
the long texts these elements are used
to explain project examples review
research publications and link the
content to known databases from which
the user can learn to navigate each
topic is reinforced through practical
application
this element relies on running
bioinformatics practice pipelines to
help make them logical the analysis
steps are color-coded and feature
pop-ups with in-depth explanations as
well as links to relevant publications
the pipeline's are prepared in advance
to provide quick outputs to help
understand how they function finally
course material is reviewed into module
quizzes and tests these are timed and
tied in with the student overall
progress during the course students and
faculties will be able to see how they
make progress through the courses
complete practical assignments and
perform the quizzes
this data is crunched to provide the
basis of certification at the conclusion
of their journey through the material
let's review how these elements work
using transcriptomics one as an example
the goal of this course is to provide
the learner with relevant information to
understand the biology of transcription
learn about the process of next
generation sequencing apply
computational tools to process short
reads of sequences turn them into
structured data and then prepare a table
of gene or isoform expression that is
ready for analysis to do so we have to
make sure key terms are defined in
informatics related terminology is
linked to the biology of transcription
thus we can prepare students to have a
better understanding of genes exons the
process of alternative splicing and how
these are represented in RNA seek data
these terms also help prepare students
to understand the need for certain types
of analysis methods that might not be
clear from their names as they are used
by bioinformaticians
such as top hat bowtie or arsim placing
these terms and concepts together in the
text videos and explanatory pop-ups on
the practice platforms helps to maintain
engagement it also provides direction
and reinforces learning throughout their
practice module video tutorials are
meant to provide a further in-depth look
at specific concepts such as the central
dogma of molecular biology these offer
insight into how specific methods or
data is used or explain the need for
analysis approaches such as principal
component analysis and classification
these are explained using projects for
example we use the patient derives ena
grass mouse model project to demonstrate
the use of mapping on two different
genomes as an informatics approach to
study the role of tumor
micro-environment
in cancer studies to make these concepts
practical we offer students a way to
gain practical experience and apply
their knowledge to build analysis
pipelines our platform is integrated
into the learning process with the goal
of using the same color coding to review
in-depth explanations link terminology
to its function these pipelines also
require data input so the students learn
to find data from public domain
databases such as NCBI EMBL or TCGA the
module quizzes have been written and
scrutinized heavily so that they provide
an effective assessment tool for
instructors as well as effective
feedback for the students in addition to
the quizzes we will offer elements of
gamification students and faculties will
see points levels and badges that can be
used for the group context and are used
in our certification process I encourage
all of you to take a look at the LB R
and T bio info link there you'll be able
to review the courses and see how some
of what I mentioned is implemented you
can also create a profile and track your
own progress throughout the course and
see how much effort goes into successful
course completion
you will notice most of what I've said
as you navigate the portal and look
through the course material take quizzes
or practice running practice pipelines
on the T bio info platform
you